when we talk about
your run benny the butcher was here
burden of proof you and him crazy
uh you're you're uh
just love with griselda has been lit
you're on um conway's album the record
he just put out with dave shout out to
um
um but yeah you and benny i remember i
was so excited to see y'all in like last
year i hit you i was like well i gotta
pull up here with y'all cooking
like because because gizelle is some of
my favorite [ __ ] and you're one of my
favorite producers and
and i think it's like a a match
that i i knew was going to be fire but
it
seems like you know wait griselda and
hit boy
i mean i feel like that that was with
the 9 [ __ ] too you know
people was like man i don't know what
this about to sound like so
for me to um always have this versatile
like
mentality and just versatile sound and
for people to think i only did club
records that this was a perfect
opportunity for me to
dial in with artists who have that crowd
that's going to be able to show like
damn like it really is that you know
saying on all levels
like you could do it out like i feel
like any you know
anybody can chase was hot in the club
right now but to make those timeless
album cuts sometimes
records um what would like again i'm
sure it was like
you and benny probably chopping it up
and then he comes through and then it's
like oh we should just do
a whole project i mean how did that
y'all saw him come to l.a
we had never even chopped it i just hit
him like bruh if you uh if you got time
while you're out here just pull up i got
some [ __ ]
he came through first record we did i'm
like this [ __ ] a classic
hit up saying first song so i'm like we
got to keep going
once again he kept pulling up before you
knew it we had an album done like it's
really been simple math like
just having that [ __ ] on deck having
some soulful having something hard like
just having different sounds and people
they gravitating towards
you know i'm saying without without it
being some watered down [ __ ] what do you
think
it is about uh the griselda [ __ ]
benny conway that the chemistry between
you guys is so natural being somebody
who's traditionally looked at us
somebody who's out of you know cali you
know what i'm saying and those guys are
so
extremely yeah underground east coast
boom bap [ __ ] i mean i just [ __ ] with
music period bro
you know what i'm saying like whether
it's i'm on the radio whether it's
something i'm hearing out on the random
like
i just [ __ ] with anything that feel like
something and feel you know feel like
they doing it with intention like you
know saying
every bar them boys is serious about
this [ __ ] you know saying you could tell
and people who take the crap serious
when you when they link up you know
you're gonna get some beautiful nine
times out of ten so
i'm taking my [ __ ] serious the whole
gazelle today on they wave so
you know we locked in